cela ne faut pas imaginer qu'il suffit
simplement d'avoir un pays pauvre pour
que l'islam c'est un big mac sont
embrigadés ils ont été séduits ils ont
été manipulés et d'autres qui agissent
de manière parfaitement consciente et
lucide je respecterai toujours mon
adversaire même si je méprise totalement
son idéologie comme c'est le cas pour
sega liste
[Musique]
à la une le président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky demande un sommet
avec ses homologues russe français et la
chancelière allemande objectif tenter
d'apaiser les tensions avec moscou un
appel lancé à paris à l'issue d'une
rencontre avec et mener le maquereau
auquel angela merkel a participé en
visio conférence est les trois
dirigeants plaident pour un retrait des
troupes russes à la frontière avec le
crâne de son côté le kremlin souhaite le
respect des accords de minsk
[Musique]
servage ovarian brésilien pour y
parvenir la guyane s'organise couvre-feu
renforcer renforts venus de la métropole
pour accélérer la vaccination ou encore
festin anti g league requis pour les
voyageurs en métropole nous ferons
points dans cette édition
evian birmanie l'union européenne
prépare une nouvelle série de sanctions
contre les militaires au pouvoir depuis
le coup d'état du 1er février à de
nouvelles représailles en réponse à la
répression sanglante menée contre les
manifestants
de son côté l'opposition s'organise
en solidaire a annoncé la création d'un
gouvernement d'unité nationale
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france le cren à
demande un sommet format normandie avec
la russie la france et l'allemagne son
président volodymyr zelensky rencontrer
son homologue français à l'elysée un
sommet tripartite à distance avec la
chancelière allemande angela merkel
les trois partis ont réclamé le retrait
des troupes russes regroupés à la
frontière on attend maintenant la
réaction de moscou qui demandent le
respect des accords de minsk
dans ce contexte le président ukrainien
a réitéré le souhait de son pays
d'adhérer à l'otan et à l'union
européenne on écoute on l'écoutait
justement au terme de la réunion il a
rappelé que l'europe elle aussi était
impliqué dans le combat
je suis conscient que c'est notre
problème mais je pense qu'il ne s'agit
pas seulement de nous mais de la
sécurité de l'europe
quand toute l'europe comprendra que
c'est la sécurité de tous les européens
nous avancerons ensemble très rapidement
du mauvais vers le bong vers des mesures
concrètes et pour françois constantine
et géopolitologue il ne faut pas
s'attendre à beaucoup d'évolution tant
que l'ukraine ne respecte pas les
accords dame inc ce qu'il faut craindre
c'est qu'elles soient en quelque sorte
partial aujourd'hui l'ukraine n'a pas
besoin d'être mis en balance dans cette
fracture de nouvelle guerre froide que
l'on déploie en europe mais elle a
plutôt besoin d'être neutralisé les
accords de miss go il faisait mx2 il
faut les appliquer de façon intégrale
c'est à dire le cessez-le-feu le retrait
de troupes armées et le fait que
l'ukraine applique notamment sa
disposition très importante dans les
accords de messieurs qui est d'accorder
l'autonomie constitutionnelle au région
de lougansk est donné ce qu'elle n'a pas
fait pour l'instant est en effet à
partir de partir de là de cette non
application des accords de mise 2 les
choses peuvent pas avancer sur le
terrain comment la population vit
la situation ont fait le point depuis
donesk avec notre envoyé spécial antoine
claireaux pendant qu'on débattait du
sort du dombass à paris entre le
président français le président
ukrainien et la chancelière allemande
eh bien nous sommes allés à la rencontre
des habitants de donetsk afin de leur
demander ce qu'ils pensent et d'un
rapprochement entre l'ukraine et l'otan
ce qui est le souhait du président
ukrainien je vous propose d'écouter
certaines de leurs réponses cela nous
est égal nous sommes neutres des
personnes à politique nous sommes
probablement résigné vis-à-vis de la
situation
voici ce que je pense
égoutter et je sais que le temps a été
créée après la guerre pour contenir
l'influencé soviétique et on ne comprend
pas bien qu'elle est maintenant le but
de cette alliance militaire
je n'ai pas d'opinion politique pourquoi
parce que tout ce qui est fait est fait
au détriment des intérêts de la
population
tous ceux qui sont au pouvoir agissent
contre le peuple
je veux que les gens aillent bien qu'ils
aient des emplois un système de santé et
une éducation surtout dans notre pays
qui est riche et maintenant les gens
sont pauvres
donc je suis contre toute influence
politique dans le donbass la situation
diffère grandement si l'on vit dans le
centre d'une grande ville comme à
donetsk où nous nous trouvons par
exemple ou ici les russes ont entretenu
les magasins sont ouverts les gens
vaquent à leurs occupations
mais par contre dès qu'on s'éloigne un
petit peu dès qu'on arrive dans ces
villages qui se trouvent au niveau de la
ligne de contact au niveau de cette
ligne de front et bien l'histoire est
complètement différente les habitants
que nous avons rencontrés hier à
l'occasion d'un reportage nous ont dit
qu'ils avaient peur peur que des
projectiles tombe dans leur jardin sur
leur maison sur leur voiture et
d'ailleurs ces dernières 24 heures les
autorités du dombass ont fait savoir
qu'il y avait eu un mort à mort parmi
les civils
à la suite de bombardements du crime
les tensions également entre la russie
et les etats unis moscou a annoncé
aujourd'hui qu'elle allait expulser
diplomates américains
décision prise en réponse aux mesures
annoncées par washington hier
l'administration bayh dole reproche à
moscou d'être à l'origine d'une
cyberattaque géante l'accusent
d'ingérence dans l'élection américaine
de novembre à ce que dément le kremlin
qui condamne des sanctions qui juge
inacceptable ont fait le point en direct
avec notre correspondante à moscou vera
goffman verra bonjour quelles sont les
mesures prises par moscou fin bonjour se
monte à lâcher le chef de la diplomatie
russe sergueï lavrov a évoqué une série
de mesures de représailles telles que
l'interdiction faite aux représentations
diplomatiques américaines en russie d'un
beau chez les russes ou des citoyens
d'autres pays autres que les états-unis
et en renforcement des restrictions dans
les déplacements des diplomates
américains sur le territoire russe la
russie va restreindre et mettre fin aux
activités sur son territoire des
fondations et ouais j'aime bien qu'un
pigeon site pratique ouvertement
l'ingérence dans notre vie politique
intérieure
le conseiller du président russe a
également recommandé à l'ambassadeur
américain john sullivan de retourner à
washington pour consultation je vous
propose d'écouter l'ambassadeur antonoff
poursuit ses consultations
la situation possède de nombreuses
strates et nous avons besoin de
l'examiner en détail
de plus ce qui se passe à washington
n'est pas toujours très clair pour cette
raison aujourd'hui
iouri ouchakov a conseillé à
l'ambassadeur john sullivan de se rendre
dans sa capitale afin d'y mener des
consultations approfondies et sérieuse
en parallèle immédiatement après cette
conférence de presse nous publierons une
déclaration du ministre des affaires
étrangères décrivant toutes les mesures
que nous avons approuvé le président
russe les a approuvés en réponse aux
actions totalement inamicale et dénué de
cause qui ont été annoncées par
washington à l'encontre de la fédération
de russie de nos citoyens individus et
entités ainsi que de notre système
financier
ces marchés financiers le ministère
russe des affaires étrangères a
également publié une déclaration
détaillée concernant les sanctions et
les relations russo américaines
moscou a en même temps perçoit de
manière positive l'idée d'un sommet
byden poutine
malgré une nouvelle volée de sanctions
et contre sanctions entre les deux pays
merci beaucoup verhaeghe of mana pour
toutes ces précisions en direct depuis
moscou fonds pour faire face aux
variants brésilien la martinique se
confiner la guyane renforce ces
restrictions le gouvernement demande
désormais aux voyageurs en provenance de
guyane d'effectuer un test antigénique
en plus du test pcr négatif et d'être en
possession d'un motif impérieux
obligatoire pour voyager la préfecture
annonce également la mise en place d'un
couvre-feu de 19h à 5h du matin pour
toute la semaine sur une grande partie
du département
à l'hôpital le plan blanc et déclencher
des infirmières parisienne sont
mobilisés en renfort et la vaccination
ci est aussi accéléré écouter ces
réactions de personnel soignant
nous sommes organisés pour fonctionner
tous les jours je le dis haut à partir
de ce week end à 0
tous les jours de 7 heures à 17 heures
et à partir du 1er mai des poivrons
la vaccination du lundi au vendredi de
7h à 21h aux grecs depuis qu'on parle de
ce variant brésilien aux enfants j'ai
l'impression qu'on en parle de plus en
plus on sent vraiment au mexique et chez
des gens qui viennent se faire vacciner
qui ont besoin d'être rassurés qu'ils
nous demandent si le vaccin est vraiment
efficace pour l'intérieur brésilien une
lente il vraiment utile qui ne demandent
qu'on en pense notre avis et oui c'est
vrai que ça c'est d'un troll doit de
rassurer la population face à ces
inquiétudes
on va écouter félix lomba il est médecin
généraliste à cayenne selon lui le
dépistage et la vaccination constitue
des clés pour maîtriser le variant
brésilien en guyenne les choses sont
évolue lentement mais nous essayons en
tout cas des rassurer nos patients les
variants brésilien est bien présent et
d'ailleurs devient majoritaire par
rapport sur les cas de contamination ici
en guyane mais on peut dire que la
situation est encore contrôlable il faut
faire de la pédagogie inciter les gens à
se faire vacciner est en tout cas se
faire dépister
pour l'instant ce n'est pas encore
catastrophique les deux préfet a pris
des dispositions qui sont déjà connus
c'est à dire qu'il y aura un couvre-feu
à partir du samedi 17 des 19 heures
jusqu'au lundi à 5 heures du matin c'est
des mesures qui ont déjà été prises par
le passé qu'ils ont montré une certaine
efficacité
c'est qu'il faut dire c'est qu'il faut
se rappeler de la frontière qui existe
entre la guyane et le brésil c'est une
frontière longue difficile à contrôler
assez poreuse quand même et on a des
gens qui viennent de part et d'autre qui
peuvent aggraver la situation locale qui
est déjà fragile mais à l'heure actuelle
nous notre travail a tant que médecin
c'est d'essayer dé rassurer nos patients
mais des pistes et au maximum les
inciter à se faire vacciner en métropole
de déconfinement se fera par étapes la
réouverture des lieux publics emmanuel
macron en a parlé hier par
visioconférence avec une dizaine de ses
ministres et quel commerce il maintient
la date du 15 mai pour la réouverture
des terrasses et des musées rien n'est
sûr pour autant et tout dépendra de la
pression hospitalière de l'avancement de
la campagne vaccinale
une chose est certaine la réouverture
des écoles 26 avril pour les maternelles
et les primaires 3 mai pour les collèges
et les lycées chiant la france qui
franchit la barre symbolique des cent
mille morts dus qu'aux vide un cap
dépassé hier selon santé publique france
alors que pour l'inserm c'est déjà le
cas depuis quelques semaines comment
l'expliquer éléments de réponse avec
bassin chebbi cent mille morts dus
coronavirus un triste chiffre franchi en
france depuis le 15 avril en cap qui a
été annoncée ce jeudi par santé publique
france dans son bilan quotidien bien
après l'institut national de la santé et
de la recherche médicale qui évoquait
déjà ce cap fatidique depuis plusieurs
semaines comme nous avons pu la prendre
en consultant les données encore
partielles publiées le 9 avril et
présenté par le directeur de recherche
de l'inserm de façon délibérée ou non
santé publique france semble minimiser
c'est le nombre de décès retardant de la
sorte passage de ce cap fatidique des
100 mille victimes
djokovic 19 dans l'hexagone alors qu'une
institution publique de santé révèle
progressivement et rapidement le nombre
de décès au quotidien ou presque du côté
de l'inserm on préfère jouer la carte du
recul et d'une meilleure précision à
l'inserm ce à partir de l'ensemble des
certificats de décès rempli par les
médecins que ces chiffres sont
déterminés ils permettent ainsi les
études par sexe et par tranches d'âge
mais aussi selon la zone géographique de
l'ensemble des victimes
une technique
expliquer l'écart de plus de onze mille
17 entre les deux organismes pour la
période allant du 1er mars au 31
décembre 2020 il y à déjà 75 1732
certificat mentionnant le kovy 19 comme
cause initiale ou associés de la mort au
31 décembre 2020 le tableau de bord de
l'épidémie de santé publique france
faisait lui état de 64 1632 décès
toujours selon l'inserm le sidikou
systèmes d'information pour le suivi des
victimes bénéficient d'une surveillance
qui contiendrait plusieurs angles morts
est responsable de cet écart de données
avec l'inserm
par exemple elle ne tient pas compte des
morts à domicile ni même ceux survenus
dans les unités de soins de longue durée
environ 30 me lis sur l'ensemble du
territoire ce qui a pour double effet
non seulement de réduire le nombre de
morts mais également de masques et le
nombre de victimes ayant été contaminées
en milieu hospitalier
les décès survenant aux urgences dans
les services de psychiatrie de soins de
suite et de réadaptation ne sont pas
bien dénombré ce qu'ils sous-estiment
beaucoup de cas nosocomiaux l'écart est
donc bien réel révélateur d'un
dysfonctionnement dans le décompte et le
fonctionnement 10 min et des décès dans
cette épidémie on devrait pouvoir
communiquer avec fiabilité sur les décès
de la veille
la solution serait simple rendre
obligatoire pour tout médecin la
certification électronique des décès
dans les 48 heures même si pour
l'exécutif ce cap des cent mille morts
vient juste d'être atteints il
semblerait malheureusement que ce
chiffre soit déjà dépassé selon l'inserm
qui pointe du doigt santé publique
france dont les données semblent
largement sous-estimées s'agit-il d'une
volonté du gouvernement de présenter un
bilan plus favorable
afin de se prémunir des critiques dans
sa gestion de la crise sanitaire ou ce
décalage n'est-il que technique
imputable au mode de calcul employée
difficile d'en avoir la certitude mais
de nombreuses voix s'élèvent pour
réclamer la généralisation de la
certification électronique de décès
autrement dit la dématérialisation du
certificat de décès traditionnellement
édité par le médecin qui mettrait fin à
cette bataille des chiffres et des plus
morbides
on en vient à la crise en birmanie
l'union européenne tape du poing sur la
table elle prépare une série de
sanctions contre les militaires au
pouvoir depuis le coup d'état du 1er
février il s'agit de représailles à la
répression sanglante menée contre les
manifestants et cela fait plusieurs mois
que la société civile appelle à la
communauté internationale à intervenir
ont fait le point avec l ain masculine
la liste noire s'allonge sur la table du
conseil européen une nouvelle étape dans
la condamnation des violences exercées
par la junte birmane
les nouvelles cibles de bruxelles
devrait être dévoilé dès la semaine
prochaine une liste va être adopté il y
a eu un accord sur dix personnes et deux
entités il y a eu une discussion sur les
entreprises liées à la junte a ajouté et
un accord a été trouvé pour deux d'entre
elles des sanctions qui s'ajoutent à
celles déjà décidées le 22 mars par lieu
parmi les personnalités visées le chef
de la junte le général ming wang ling
neuf des plus hauts gradés des forces
armées ainsi que le président de la
commission électorale
cette punition européenne comprend une
interdiction de se rendre ou même de
transiter par l'ue et un gel des avoirs
sur le sol européen et la suspension des
possibilités de financement des
entreprises nommées par bruxelles ces
sanctions suivent des mesures
comparables décidée par le royaume uni
et les etats unis qui visent deux
conglomérats birman liés aux militaires
considérées comme des sources de
financement de la junte alors que la
répression a déjà fait plus de 700 morts
dont 50 enfants et donné lieu à quelque
3000 arrestations
l'opposition continue de s'organiser
dans le pays où un de ses leaders a
annoncé la création d'un gouvernement
d'unité nationale composée de députés
proches donc sans doute y est supposé
représenter l'ensemble des ethnies du
pays
je voudrais annoncer la formation d'un
gouvernement d'unité nationale comme nos
citoyens l'attendait veuillez soutenir
le gouvernement d'unité nationale
les citoyens sont les décideurs et ce
sont eux qui mèneront la bataille finale
la victoire est proche
nous devons réussir cette révolution
l'un des principaux objectifs de ce
gouvernement d'unité sera de gagner le
soutien et la reconnaissance de la
communauté internationale
pendant ce temps aux nations unies pas
de réaction concrète et ce malgré
l'appel des civil birman a adopté des
mesures fortes au brésil la voie est
libre pour l'ancien président lula la
cour suprême du pays à annuler les
accusations de corruption à son encontre
rien ne l'en empêche désormais de se
présenter la prochaine élection
présidentielle
et cela même si lula n'a pas encore
confirmé officiellement son envie de
revenir au pouvoir
en tout cas s'ils franchissent pas le
brésil pourrait se diriger en 2022
vers un duel oulhadj ailleurs bolton
arrow l'actuel président on voit cela
avec isabelle carré secousse un verdict
qui pourrait avoir des conséquences sur
le prochain scrutin présidentiel
la cour suprême brésilienne a confirmé
hier l'annulation des condamnations pour
corruption de l'ancien président lula
une première victoire qui le relance
dans l'arène politique
c'était un très gros mensonge mais mes
avocats ont prouvé que c'était une
imposture
le juge a menti les avocats menti
la police fédérale a menti pour
m'éloigner de la campagne électorale
maintenant je suis prêt pour le combat
en 2017 et 2018
luiz inacio da silva dit lula est
condamné à plus de 12 ans de prison pour
corruption et blanchiment dans la sphère
petrobras il est emprisonné inéligible à
la présidentielle de 2010 8 en février
2019 il est condamné dans une autre
affaire à 12 ans et 11 mois de prison
pour corruption et blanchiment dans la
sphère de la rénovation de l'une de ses
propriétés
mais le 8 mars dernier un juge du
tribunal suprême fédéral annule ses
condamnations estimant que le tribunal
qui l'a condamné dans les deux procès
n'était pas compétent la cour suprême a
confirmé hier le verdict confirmant
aussi l'égibilité de l'ex président à un
troisième mandat
alors que j'aï rebelles sauna roller ne
déjà vers la présidentielle de 2022
les hostilités sont d'ores et déjà
ouvertes entre les deux probables aux
candidats comparer des ministres de lula
avec nos ministres c'est lula est de
retour par un vote direct un vote
vérifiables d'accord mais imaginer ce
que sera le futur du brésil avec le
genre de personne qu'il va faire entrer
dans l'exécutif
les juges de la cour suprême nino sont
pas l'ancien syndicaliste sur le fond et
devront décider s'ils ordonnent le
transfert du dossier un autre tribunal
en attendant une possible
l'officialisation de sa candidature
lula affûte ses armes face à bolton a
row dont la cote de popularité
s'effondre avec le coronavirus que son
adversaire avait qualifié de plus gros
génocide de l'histoire du brésil
le coc vide 19 qui a fait à ce jour plus
de 365 milles morts l'histoire se répète
aux etats unis une nouvelle vidéo
choquante qui montera un policier en
train de tirer sur un mineur de 13 ans
de quoi enflammer de nouveau le pays en
plein procès d'éric chauvin ce policier
accusé de l'assassinât de georges floyd
on voit cela avec un maxime a bola les
états unis serait-il sur le point
d'imploser
une nouvelle vidéo d'une possible bavure
policière vient mettre le feu aux
poudres en rendue publique par les
autorités de chicago ce jeudi les faits
remontent au 29 mars dernier elle y
montre un jeune adolescent adam toledo
courant poursuivi par le policier le
jeune latino de 13 ans s'arrête puis
lève les mains sans armes apparentes
avant le coup de feu du policier nous
vivons dans une ville traumatisée par
une longue histoire de violences est de
mauvaise conduite de la police alors
bien que nous n'ayons pas assez
d'informations pour être le juge et le
jury de sa situation particulière il est
certainement compréhensible que tant de
nos résidents ressentent une vague
d'indignation et de douleur bien trop
familière mais encore une fois je
demande instamment je demande instamment
à chaque résident qui se soucie et aime
cette ville d'attendre jusqu'à ce que
nous entendions tous les faits white
on peut faire face à dan toledo n'est
pas le seul à avoir été tué par la
police américaine cette semaine
ce dimanche le jeune afro-américain
d'interights a été abattu par une
policière dans la banlieue de
minneapolis lors d'un contrôle routier
la policière kim potter a assuré avoir
confondu son arme de service et son
pistolet électrique taser inculpé pour
homicide involontaire
elle encourt jusqu'à dix ans de prison
un drame qui a ravivé des fortes
tensions à minneapolis avec plusieurs
manifestations ces derniers jours et des
heurts entre protestataires et forces de
l'ordre
la seule question qui se pose à nous
aujourd'hui est de savoir si le nom de
danté white va rejoindre la liste des
afro américains qui ont été injustement
tué par la police qui n'ont pas obtenu
que la police soit tenu pour responsable
tant de nos enfants ont été tués par les
personnes qui sont censés les protéger
et les servir dans des situations très
suspecte est très controversée cette
nouvelle bavure policière met de l'huile
sur le feu à minneapolis ville ou de
georges floyd a été tué en mai dernier
et dont le procès de derek chauvine
accusé de son meurtre se déroule
actuellement
après plusieurs semaines de débats
l'ancien policier a invoqué ce jeudi son
droit au cinquième amendement de la
constitution américaine
monsieur nelson prend beaucoup de
décisions au cours du procès mais il ne
peut pas décider pour vous si vous aller
témoigner ou non et il peut vous donner
des conseils et vous pouvez suivre ces
conseils ou les rejeter mais la décision
finale doit être la vôtre et non la
sienne est votre décision de ne pas
témoigner
ce jeune c'est le cas votre honneur le
verdict du procès de derrick chauvine
prévue pour fin avril est très attendue
aux etats-unis son dénouement pourrait
avoir de lourdes conséquences à travers
le pays
si le policier venait à être acquitté
beaucoup redoutent des débordements à la
hauteur des manifestations et des
émeutes
après la mort de georges floyd des
images de violence encore aux états unis
avec cette fusillade d'hier un gain la
police dans un centre à des groupes de
transport de lettres et colis fedex
huit personnes sont mortes au moins dix
autres ont été blessés le responsable se
serait suicidé une fusillade de masse
qui survient après celle de mars qui ont
relancé le débat très sensible sur la
prolifération des armes à feu dans le
pays
on prend la direction de la république
centrafricaine mois de ramadan
particulier rassemblement restreint
déplacements limités l'ambiance est
différente cette année encore sur fond
de crise sanitaire et sécuritaire voyez
ce reportage avec la communauté
musulmane signait pas kumpa bandji avec
le récit de syrian benavides vlb lyon
dans son salon à amath reçoit la visite
de moussa les deux leaders musulmans
discutent du prêche du jour basée sur la
réconciliation entre chrétiens et
musulmans mais surtout sur la paix la
république centrafricaine traverse
depuis quatre mois une crise militaire
et politique en dépit de l'élection
présidentielle le 27 décembre dernier
depuis une coalition de plusieurs
groupes rebelles menacent de renverser
le président faustin archange touadéra
laissant le pays dans une instabilité
sécuritaire notre symbole c'est de prier
et d'avoir un centrafrique min et les
conseillers et autres mouvements
chrétiens c'est de travailler ensemble
dans le sens de la paix et d'éviter la
manipulation tarn où plus on tient seul
dieu et nous adorons qu'un seul dieu et
ensemble nous allons aboutir pour
changer la mentalité pour développer
notre pays
la prière du jour se déroule dans cette
rue que les habitants du quartier
musulman du pk5 surnommé le couloir de
la mort à cause des nombreuses
qui ont eu lieu ici même il y a
plusieurs mois aujourd'hui c'est tout un
symbole les activités ont repris et la
vie elle aussi reprend son cours
une dizaine de croyants prennent part à
la prière sous une chaleur intense
tous demandent la paix dans le pays s'il
n'y a pas la paix on ne peut même pas
faire le ramadan
on ne peut pas faire du commerce on ne
peut pas aller à l'église ni à la
mosquée
donc la paix est capital le ramadan se
sont tous les musulmans du monde entier
qui le font y compris ceux d'ici nous
pensons donc en priorité à prier pour
notre pays en 2013 une rébellion à
majorité musulmane avait pris le pouvoir
s'en étaient suivies de nombreux
assassinats visant des chrétiens du pays
cela avait entraîné la création d'un
groupe armé à dominante chrétienne la
milice dénommée antibalas qu'à s'en
prenant essentiellement aux musulmans
conséquence le pays s'était retrouvée
plongée dans une guerre de religion
dorénavant les musulmans veulent
recoller les morceaux et espère profiter
du mois de ramadan pour le faire et
c'est la fin journal merci à vous de
l'avoir sujet on va se retrouver dans 30
minutes reste avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]